[Music]
karissa you asked the question about how
religion affects our view of the cosmos
and the first thing I think about is
simply the history of being human there
were so many things about the universe
that we didn't understand you know
thousands of years ago we watched the
seasons changed or we observe things
like thunderstorms and we had no idea we
didn't have the scientific knowledge to
explain these things and so it seems
like a very natural understandable human
instinct to try to ascribe these things
to two gods two beings that are so much
more powerful than us we can barely
comprehend them and that sort of way of
interpreting nature as as spirits and
things that are much more powerful than
us I find very beautiful then of course
what happens is you learn you learn what
causes lightning you know the ancient
Scandinavians might have said it was the
God for actually causing lightning well
we know it's not Thor it actually has to
do with friction inside clouds and
generating electric charges we
understand now why the Sun shines and
why the seasons change and there seems
to be this instinct to always put God
farther and farther away so now that we
understand thunderstorms maybe God lives
in the sky we just put the idea of God
farther away from what we know people
say okay well now we understand how
planets work and how galaxies work but
maybe God set off the Big Bang why are
we always pushing God away why are we
always making the concept of whatever
God is farther and farther and farther
and as soon as we have scientific
knowledge about something we say okay
well you know that's not God God must be
farther out still there's never been a
time in human history where we realized
that some things had scientific
explanations and some things didn't it's
like okay well we know why the Sun
shines we know why the seasons change
but lightning that really is Thor that
actually never happens everything that
we explore we actually add to our body
of knowledge and while I am NOT
personally religious it seems to me to
be a disservice to the idea of God that
God constantly gets farther and farther
away you put that
him or however you want to call it just
outside the grasp of human knowledge
someday we will understand what set off
the Big Bang and I don't think the
answer is going to be God maybe God is
something more personal to you maybe
it's how you relate to other people
maybe it's how you define your morality
maybe it's something that's very very
important in our culture but I also
think that we do the university's
service because we're putting our own
ego our own vision of ourselves out
there there are many religions that seem
to think of God as something like a
person some very very powerful version
of a human being and there are other
religions that don't that talk about
natural forces or or gods that are
incomprehensible but all of them seem to
be too much about putting our own selves
our own fears our own version of what
morality should be out on to the
universe and the universe really doesn't
care about any of that I sort of wish we
observed the universe the way it is and
then turn it back on ourselves we are a
reflection of the physical laws around
us people often say why is the universe
so perfectly tuned that human life can
exist at all why do we have the right
temperature planet around them the most
perfect type of star you can have you
know why are all the physical laws
exactly what you need for matter to hold
together and this to me always seemed
like putting the cart before the horse
we are a product of the laws of the
universe you know the reason we have
evolved to be this type of biology is
because we evolved on this planet there
may be creatures that evolved on very
different planets that are asking the
same question why are we on the perfect
planet for life but there methane-based
fish somewhere on Titan I mean who knows
you have to really understand that the
universe has nothing to do with our
vision but our minds our sense of beauty
our sense of mathematics and how things
fit together they do work really well
with the physical laws of the universe
but that's not a coincidence
they evolved inside the universe our
minds came to consciousness with these
physical laws in these conditions
so I think we actually can learn more
about the larger universe by studying
ourselves better why is that we enjoy
the golden ratio in mathematics how do
our minds really reflect what the
physical Const
since the laws of nature are I find that
wonderfully rich and it helps me fit
into the larger context of the universe
which I think is the most noble goal of
any religion
[Music]